um we were in our apartment and he went
into the bathroom for one of his
sessions he was maybe like 20 minutes
into his usual 45 minutes when I started
to feel some fireworks so I texted him
and I was like hey I'm about to shoot my
pants and he doesn't respond like I can
hear his phone get my text and I hear
him just like continue to watch Arrested
Development I'm like
so then I start frantically looking
around our tiny like one bedroom
apartment for a substitute toilet and
the first thing I saw was the kitchen
sink but then I like right away I was
like too high that's a lot of gymnastics
that I'm not qualified for especially
when you're about to shoot yourself
about to shoot yourself this push right
here
a little hop over here like
[Laughter]